pour ne louper aucune vidéo abonnez vous
et activer la petite cloche
bonjour les épis curieuse et des épis
curieux si vous demandez à quelqu'un
dans la rue
de quelle couleur sont les carottes
cette personne vous répondra sans
hésitation il y à quelques milliers
d'années pourtant durant l'antiquité on
vous aurait fait une toute autre réponse
car à l'époque les carottes étaient
blanches elle ressemblait à une sorte de
panais rabougris et probablement quand
vous répond dans votre interlocutrice ou
votre interlocuteur aurait esquissé une
petite grimace
les carottes étaient alors sauvage tout
maigrichons très dur légèrement épicé et
âpre au goût du coup nos ancêtres
préféré consommer les graines de
carottes plutôt que la racine les
premières carottes de couleurs sont
sortis de terre il est environ 1000 ans
du côté de l'afghanistan
elles sont jaunes ou pourpre petit à
petit leurs cultures et leur
consommation
c'est en aux pays voisins elle débarque
sur les tables de france d'allemagne et
des pays-bas au 14e siècle
à ce stade toujours pas de carotte
orange les premières voit le jour deux
siècles plus tard dans l'un des pays
d'accueil est les pays bas elle est
vraisemblablement issu du croisement de
plusieurs variétés de carottes jaunes
son succès est immédiat sûrement un peu
à cause de sa couleur
le range est en effet celle des princes
des pays bas mais pas seulement
cette carotte est aussi très charnue et
plus sucré que les carottes blanches et
puis à la différence des carottes
pourpre elle ne déteint pas dans l'eau
de cuisson et ne colorent pas les autres
aliments du coup quand cette carotte
orange débarque c'est un peu râpé pour
les autres aujourd'hui plusieurs
variétés anciennes et colorée refont
surface et sont disponibles sur les
marchés
la bonne nouvelle c'est qu'elles sont
toutes excellentes pour la santé
la carotte orange contient carotène le
pigment qui est responsable de sa
couleur un précurseur de la vitamine b
c'est aussi un anti oxydantes comme les
anthocyanes
qui colorent les carottes pourpre elles
contiennent aussi de la vitamine b1 b2
et de la vitamine c elle se mange en
toute saison
car elle se récolte du mois de mai au
mois de février suivant elle se troquent
crue ou cuite se mange entière ou râpé
et on en fait aussi un excellent et en
plus roddick ça rend aimable tient
faudra que je crois que cette histoire
allait santé ça sent bon
si vous avez aimé cette vidéo n'hésitez
pas à laisser un pouce bleus
merci les épis curieux pour les plus
gourmands en voici d'autres et pour ne
rien rater
abonnez vous et activer la cloche
[Musique]